السته الاف مدني اوكرانيا لقوا حتفهم منذ
بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا جراء
الضربات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه الروسيه
حصيله ثقيله دفعت بريطانيا مره جديده الى
اصدار عقوبات شامله 12 قائدا بارزا في
الجيش الروسي بينهم قائد لوحده توصل تحقيق
الى ان الوحده مسؤوله عن برمجه وتوجيه
الصواريخ الروسيه ديهاكات خطيره للقانون
الانساني الدولي حسب البيان الذي اكد على
ضروره محاسبه المسؤولين عن هذه الهجمه
ايران مشموله بالعقوبه الجديده التي طالت
شركه مادو الايرانيه ومديرها يوسف ابو
طالبي والمسؤوله بمنظمه الجهاد للاكتفاء
الذاتي والبحوث التابعه للحرس الثوري عبد
الله محرابي ورئيس منظمه الصناعات الجويه
الايرانيه افشين خواجا فرد
الخارجيه البريطانيه اكدت ان الطائرات
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع لعب الدور الرئيسي
في الهجمات الروسيه على المدنيين
باوكرانيا
غير مقبوله على سبيل المثال توفير مسيله
عسكريه والتي يتم استخدامها في المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه من قبل روسيا في
اوكرانيا لقد فرضنا عقوبات على المطورطين
في ذلك
واشار البيان الى ان معلومات اصدرتها
الولايات المتحده مؤخرا تظهر ان ايران
اصبحت احد اكبر الداعمين العسكريين لروسيا
وان طهران ارسلت مئات الطائرات المسيره
الى روسيا في انتهاك الالتزاماتها
القانونيه الدوليه